ah welcome back everyone to another tick
tock video I mean the first tick tock
video were ever doing is this getting
off I still enjoy it okay they're still
funny some of them you just maybe like
2% of them are funny that's what we're
focusing on today hopefully is anyone
surprised no well then let's just jump
into it funny tic TOCs
let's look let's look everyone what's
the context I don't know does that make
it funnier maybe let's keep watching and
why am I in the void what is happening
here good background Felix
professional-quality as always
necessarily can't tell if this is real
what the hell is happening what the hell
in our case we'll just get kicked out
feel bad for the teacher but also funny
dick talk haha
Yee juice a it's another one of those
what's it gonna be Ricardo Sarge I can't
use the actual song because it's
copyrighted but you understand
Ricardo memes never dies am I just the
laziest boy I wish there was a more
convenient way to turn off the candle
all the way across the room oh wait
there is I just pulled this down what is
that oh it's the lady goes right on top
of that amazing and just wait just an
eternal flame will go out I was you need
to patent that right now you could be
rich
the hell has happened to tick tock like
what has happened what is this where do
you even find this what it what it just
stop please stop
Australia be like hello Mike would you
like me to throw some shrimp on the
barbie oh wow okay that's impressive
shrimp on the barbie that's epic yes
funny that's comedy funny noises hahaha
so I got acrylics for prom and now I
kind of just feel obligated to do this
what is the entire internet app together
no one likes that goddamn clip here's
know that at least I can respect if she
does that for a video redemption
complete that's all you need to do just
start a video like that missus yes salsa
quinceanera no no no there's the milk
tea Adam dad whoa I cannot be the only
person who does this well I didn't know
you can do that unicorn bro Oh
Jesus Christ
you guys have nothing else to do in your
spare time really oh god stop stop I
don't want to see this video ever again
why tick tock why no one just on their
own volition go decides I'm gonna create
tick tock because it seems so fun no one
what is this I don't get it
this is a girl joke is that wimp is his
women humor I don't get it what's
happening oh god it keeps going what
what's the joke suspicious to me
yeah so recently I've noticed that
Marcia has pink hair okay L Delphine II
has pink hair Marcia has a tongue Belle
Delphine II has a tongue and we've never
seen Marcy and beldo fini in the same
room at once what is this mean pink eyes
book that's right I am dating pink guy
everyone sorry Marcia but he's the man
of my dreams wait they're both quit
YouTube as well oh my god it checks out
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know what I just saw but there
was a video and no context whatsoever I
hope you enjoyed it as well
next tik-tok get your DSi okay the
camera yes
then take a video video got your SD card
yes plug that into your computer yes
then go to the DSi folder take the
videos yeah and drag them into your
phone now you have your new way whoa
look at that quality Wow well I guess
now you know which camera I use the fact
that fellow Nintendo DSi it's amazing
quality camera really impeccable
standards that I'm setting got a new
forklift so I can finally lift up my
cork see this is a joke that's a funny
joke he's lifting out before with a
forklift
that's what it amazing ten out of ten
does not get better
it's a Ricardo meme
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow what everyone has ever done surely
someone's done it we don't have those
type of grades in Sweden although if we
do have G VG or m VG & m VG is like the
highest grade so technically you can
just add MV in front of the G oh my deed
that's a very sweet
hmm okay
nice very very nice let's go back and
look at that again
this better be a Ricardo meme oh yeah oh
yeah no don't do it oh thank God thank
God he made it next tick tock some
things just never changed thousands ago
these kids would be fighting wars now
they're just screaming over vd logo
we've come so far I four species and I
take it all back I just take it back
everything I just said no no I don't
like it oh my god she's wearing the
merch that's the best one I've seen so
far ten out of ten yeah okay that's
another tick-tock video hope you guys
had fun leave a like if you enjoyed
subscribe and if you want to support
channel the merch Aves here did you have
fun today I would say I had fun today
I'm not nothing like distracting
yourself from the pain or being alive
for ten minutes see you guys tomorrow
[Music]
whoa Oh awesome
well but tuber simulator it's now so
relevant that it's got a brand new
minigame crania drop the crane and get
fresh items only available in the
washing machine like game and you say
there's more of course there is new
knowledge perks new quests and new pics
links and legs guys like
you
[Music]